c'est le concert de l'année en val de
loire si je vous dis mais c'est jean
battault la roxane ou encore every
breath you take on me dit sting
forcément la légende vivante du rock en
concert demain soir dans le cadre
mythique du château de chambord 20000
personnes attendues aurélie renault vous
nous en dit plus sur les coulisses de
l'événement en compagnie de votre invité
est ce n'est plus qu'une question
d'heures ici à chambord bientôt vingt
mille personnes seront ici sur la
pelouse face au château frédéric
villereau dans quel état d'esprit on est
à quelques heures de cet événement là on
est très impatient de voir le public
arrivait pour fouler ce fer à cheval
pour cet événement qui est le concert de
sting qu'on attend tous impatiemment
depuis depuis deux ans ça fait quand
même deux fois qu'il est reportée et
mettons à garder la même ferveur et ont
une grande attente du public et des de
l'ensemble des personnels de chambord le
domaine national de chambord est il déjà
accueilli un tel événement avec une
jauge si importante on a fait une jauge
quasi similaire pour le festival électro
qui s'appelait cercle il ya trois ans
maintenant
on a fait également des salons
différents salons le gars me faire
notamment où on avait une jauge
sensiblement comparable mais pas sur un
événement un concert concert de rock
avec
des gradins tribunes c'est là c'est la
première fois ta question pour vous de
parler du château comme un décor mais
plutôt comme un acteur de ce concert
c'est ça l'idée c'est de mettre en
valeur tout le domaine et bien sûr le
château qui sera derrière la scène bien
entendu changement n'est pas un fond de
scène ce sera
l'acteur il y aura deux acteurs ce
soir-là avoir trois parce qu'il ya le
public également mais en aucun cas
champ-borne de doit se limiter à un
fonds de saintes de théâtre voilà c'est
des 500 ans d'histoire et on continue
l'histoire l'histoire moderne en faisant
venir des déchets et des chanteurs au
pied du château des chanteurs un peu
engagés il faut qu'il ya un lien quelque
part avec avec notre histoire est
l'histoire de chambord alors on est loin
de la quiétude 1 dans quelques heures
puisque vingt mille personnes vont venir
ici pas d'eau pas d'électricité au
départ on le disait et donc pour vous la
condition c'est de ne pas dévasté le
paysage évidemment sinon pas de concert
ça c'est un grand défi en effet
l'endroit où va se passer le concert à
l'origine c'est une coquille vide ans
est une
c'est une pelouse où les gens viennent
pique-niquer et jouer jouer avec leurs
enfants le défi technique et de dans un
temps réduit de pouvoir cueillir 20000
personnes dans des tribunes avec un
confort
acceptable voilà c'est pour cela
d'ailleurs que on est très regardant au
choix des prestataires de la production
pour avant de s'engager quelle
visibilité pour chambord 20000 personnes
vont assister aux concerts deviennent
finalement les ambassadeurs du château
de chambord et puis il ya cette
captation puisque des caméras vont
filmer le concert qui sera retransmis
dans quelques mois ça aussi c'est
important pour le domaine c'est sûr que
d'une part 2 toutes les personnes qui
vont assister réellement à cet événement
je pense vont porter de notre image
l'image de chambord notamment aussi sur
les réseaux sociaux et vont certainement
donner l'envié à
des à leurs proches de venir visiter le
domaine et la captation
c'est un plus parce que non seulement
elle devrait toucher la france mais ça
devrait porter aussi à l'étranger est
pour rien vous cacher en ce moment on a
besoin de faire revenir revenir nos
visiteurs étrangers même s'ils sont
présents en saillé ans ils reviennent en
force mais on n'a pas encore retrouvé
j'irai le pourcentage de 2019 donc ça
peut nous aider quel est le titre qui
selon-vous frédéric bureau résonnera le
mieux d'ici quelques heures ici à
chambord je pense que que rush ian
devrait en cette époque
l'époque qu'on traverse se retenir toute
l'attention du public et à avoir une
certaine émotion symbolique particulière
merci frédéric vieillot
et merci à vous aurez listings à
chambord la suite demain pour le jour j
julien lavernhe le producteur tourangeau
de ce concert hors norme répondra à nos
questions